well we have to wait to warm up because
it is so cold out there this morning
check valley temperatures right now
not only are we in the 30s and just a
couple of degrees away from freezing in
a few places like
centennial hills the lakes we are down
below freezing
in mountains edge and seven hills green
valley at 35. it's cold this morning
prompts down in the upper 20s
mid 20s but feels sometimes like the
teens with any little breeze
and we still have 20 to 25 mile an hour
winds in laughlin
look at kingman at 23. looking for a
high of 58 today that's where we were
yesterday we didn't quite make it to 60
degrees
we were trying 59 is normal for early
december so we're very seasonal we're
supposed to be dry northeast breezes
along the river and it's still
santa ana winds in southern california
look at the snow
it's swirling starting to really look
like the holidays back in the southern
plains and the midwest today in
the mid-south all right so we'll get
back to some 60s low 60s tomorrow we'll
take our time getting back to
warmer temperatures some clouds sunday
night breezes monday and mid to upper
60s next week not a rain drop
in sight